Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Walking Dead
is finally back!
They’ve been posting a lot of clips since
Comic Con but I was still pretty blown away
with how it all went down.
I’m also re-starting my weekly walking dead
giveaway now, it’s just a weekly amazon
card given to a random subscriber in the comments.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Since there’s so much to talk about I’m
doing top 10 WTF moments, then I’ll do my
review and talk about the rest of the season.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Number 10 - Terminus Origin Story
This was a flashback to explain how the Terminus
people got to be the way they are.
How they turned into cannibals.
They cut it up across the episode and Mary
was the one that narrated the action to Carol,
but basically a group of thugs came in and
just totally tore them up.
I feel like there will be a lot of debate
about this, but it’s possible that it’s
an easter egg for Negan and the Savoirs from
the comics.
Kirkman and Gimple have said multiple times
that they’re not doing that character yet,
but that doesn’t mean they can’t squeeze
him in the same way they squeezed Morgan in
at the end.
Gimple actually said something funny on Talking
Dead, he said the the people there got so
detached from what they were doing that it
turned into the office on NBC, like a mundane
workplace sitcom.
Number 9 - Welcome to the Kill Floor
I believe that this was Robin Lord Taylor
here, the guy that Rick gave his watch to
in Season 4.
His name was Sam.
Carol found Rick’s watch later, so even
if this was not Sam, he still came through
terminus at some point.
And then passed through their intestinal tracts.
If you’ve never been on the kill floor where
they carve up cows or pigs, they bleed them
out first in trough’s like that.
The terminus people were turning the Survivors
into their cattle.
And separately from the flashback scene, slugger
here almost gets Glenn with the bat, twice.
If feel like that’s one too many times to
be a coincidence, so let’s call that another
Negan Easter Egg.
If you have read the comics, just please use
spoiler tags in the comments.
Number 8 - Carol and Tyreese Capture a Terminus
Person
They really wanted to differentiate the Terminus
People as a bad group versus the Survivors,
who also kill but are good people and a family.
Season 5 is all about them becoming family
in a deeper sense.
Abraham, Eugene and Rosita are still kind
of outsiders.
It seems like they don’t trust them enough
to explain Washington DC, but that’s a whole
other storyline.
I was really proud of Tyreese, we know exactly
how Carol is going to react in any given situation,
Tyreese was the one hopping on one foot trying
not to crush that guy’s skull.
They didn’t show it, so I keep thinking
in my head that he did the same thing to that
Terminus guy that The Mountain did to Oberyn
Martell on Game of Thrones.
I mean, the minute he threatened Baby Judith’s
life, you knew.
There was no way he was going to make it to
the next episode.
Number 7 - Carol Blows up the Gas Tanks
Carol was definitely the MVP of the episode.
And this was the best practical effect in
the episode.
Probably the most expensive too.
I loved that she went straight into rambo
mode too, no hesitation.
The minute she knew something was up she went
into auto search and destroy.
During the New York Comic Con panel she was
crying a lot, so everyone thought that meant
she was going to die.
But I have seen some of the pictures of them
filming future episodes and I can tell you,
for at least some of the season, she’s fine.
I don’t know if she’s actually going to
die later.
It’s still possible.
They not completely done filming all the episodes.
Number 6 - Machine Gun Rick
From the minute he stabbed those two guards
it was just a marathon of gore till he got
his hands on the Machine Gun.
And even after they escaped, he wanted to
go back and stomp out the rest.
I wonder how much longer he would have argued
with them if Carol hadn’t of walked up.
I don’t think he’s crazy this season,
he’ll still listen to reason.
But I think a lot of his sanity depends on
Carl and Judith.
Did anyone else think about Season 3 when
Rick started clearing the Prison out.
It was like video game levels of violence
and he had unlimited ammo.
That was the same episode that they hacked
Herschel’s leg off.
Number 5 - Eugene and The Cure
I laughed so hard when Sasha questioned Eugene
and gibberish just started pouring out of
his mouth.
He’s one of those guys that thinks if he
talks fast enough and confuses people they’ll
forget whatever is going on.
And it worked.
Eventually I do think that will be over, they’ll
have to figure out his secret.
If you’ve read the comics, just please use
spoiler tags when talking about The Cure.
And when talking about Abraham and Rick.
Their little trio are still outsiders within
the larger group of Survivors.
Sasha seems like she’s going to be the one
pushing them for answers.
Number 4 - Mary vs Carol
Battle Royal, this was the explainer for those
flashback scenes.
Scott Gimple said that they wanted to tell
the story of how Terminus became the place
we’re seeing right now.
They weren’t always cannibals.
But they just got pushed too far and snapped.
Wicked way for Tasha Yar to go.
I always love when I see her pop up on big
shows.
She got killed in an episode of Dexter during
season 1 I think too.
I think she might have been the first human
person Dexter ever killed.
Maybe Denise Crosby just likes really dark
stories.
I was really happy that they expanded her
part, she was barely in the finale last year.
Number 3 - The reunion
This was the cry-worthy moment.
Everyone is reunited.
Rick seems like he’s going to permanently
attach baby judith to his body.
They’ve been separated ever since the prison
battle.
Tyreese and Sasha too.
Did anyone else think that Daryl looked kind
of sad watching them, I feel like he was thinking
about Meryl.
Families being reunited, regardless of genetic
code they might share, they’re all a big
family now.
With the exception of the Washington DC crew.
Number 2 - Saviors Easter Egg
The second flashback gave me stronger Negan
vibes.
I don’t know if they have any other cameos
with these mystery attackers this year, but
the slicked back hair, the voice and the leather
jacket just scream Negan to me.
Number 1 - Morgan is Back
This was the real WTF, I think the scene was
only a few seconds long but it did the trick.
Robert Kirkman got asked about this a couple
days ago during Comic Con.
He said Morgan was definitely coming back
on the show, but it depended on the actor’s
schedule.
That makes me think that Morgan won’t be
a cast regular or anything, but he will have
one or two more minor cameos.
The scene just showed him tracking the survivors,
so he’ll find them eventually.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment and when do you think Morgan will be
back?
Just a heads up too, based on the teaser for
the next episode, Seth Gilliam will be introduced.
He’s playing Father Gabriel from the Comics.
I already did a video explaining him, so I’ll
add a link in the description if you want
to learn more.
Andrew J West, the guy who plays Gareth, was
also promoted to series regular.
So he’s not dead, he’ll be back.
Overall I gave the episode a solid A for making
such a roaring return to television.
Walking Dead is the most popular cable show
in the world right now, so it’s almost ridiculous
to expect it to keep one-upping itself every
week.
That being said, they usually crank all the
knobs to eleven for premieres and finales.
And this did not disappoint.
It answered a ton of questions about the characters
and did a good job of explaining what the
new dynamics of the group will be this year.
I would have liked to spend more time in the
Terminus Flashbacks but we might get more
of those when Gareth shows up again.
All things said, Rick is going to be a lot
more fun this year.
But Carol is my MVP right now.
Let me know if you agree Carol is the biggest
badass.
And don’t forget, I’ll be doing a Q&A
for this tomorrow, so leave all your questions.
I’ll announce the winner of this week’s
giveaway during that.
It’s an amazon giftcard just like last year.
Super simple.
Right now click here to get that video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here for my top 5 Rick Grimes moments.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you tomorrow!